et j'espère de tout coeur que ceux qui
viendront y vivent retrouveront la même
bonheur que monsieur et madame barrier
monsieur barrier et forgeron d'art avec
son époux ses enfants
ils ont quitté paris pour venir dans un
village très écartés du vercors rencurel
dans le rythme de vie enfin une
multitude de choses
ne serait ce que pendant un moment on
illustre sa part le passage des
concordes dans la journée trois concorde
qui pensaient relativement bas des
décibels des décibels des décibels bon
plus tous les autres avions et c'est
enfin une multitude de choses le fort
désagréable lui
on est vraiment au bout du monde chez
vous je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
vous avez voulu vous êtes des ermites
vous vous êtes retiré du monde vous avez
tout coupé devez non c'est fort simple
quand on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent on ne
trouve pas grand chose bon il y avait
cette ruine au bout du monde pour ce
qu'on pouvait l'acheter
le premier but c'était de pouvoir vivre
dans cette maison
l'intérêt c'était pas d'arriver à 60 ans
à la retraite on pouvait pas s'adapter à
la nage à 60 ans pouvait pas s'adapter à
quand on arrivait la première année on
s'est battu un peu avec les éléments
n'étaient pas installés on avait pas de
chemin pour monter c'est encore plus le
bout du monde ne manquent pas le confort
6 mai comme ça vient on apprécie s'est
remis à sa juste valeur
vous n'avez pas de salle de bains par
chez nous enfin par chez vous par chez
nous là haut
enfin disons dans la région parisienne
la salle de bain on n'y prêtait même pas
attention
c'est un objet ordinaire bon on prenait
un bain on prenait une douche comme on
fait n'importe quoi et puis maintenant
bon la nôtre est programmé là je pense
pour cet été le jour on va leur prendre
une douche ou un bain
il aura un sens il aura une valeur parce
qu'il aura été gagnée attendu on aura su
ce que c'était d'abord se laver à l'eau
froide ou de faire chauffer l'eau pour
se laver
est ce que vous l'avez trouvé où le
bonheur dans le pré du vercors
aujourd'hui je dirais qu'on a trouvé le
bonheur dans la montre
à
c'est difficile à décrire oui je sais
que c'est difficile
cet ensemble voilà pour les gammes assez
et c'est les retours de l'école en
pensant voir le veau dernier né chez le
voisin c'est pour nous le facteur qui
passe où on n'est pas une simple boîte à
lettres en ferraille où on est une
relation humaine c'est multitude de
choses
est-ce qu'on pourrait encore lui dire ce
que c'est c'est le couchant le soir sur
la falaise pour nourrir le temps du
landmark
c'est un ensemble les chiens les chats
les oiseaux qu'on voit le matin au
réveil ce qu'ils chantent le soir au
coucher
enfin louis antoine de chance de les
écouter oui il faut prendre le temps de
les écouter et on le prend en plus c'est
ça on a un rythme qui permet enfin j'ai
l'impression depuis que je suis dans
cette contrée pour donner une idée en
passant mon temps ne rien faire c'est
toujours une impression un de trouver le
moyen de d'en faire plus que je n'en
faisais avant où j'avais l'impression de
m'activer sans arrêt sans arrêt sans
arrêt sans arrêt et c'est une chose
surprenante parce que finalement le
travail on en a bien plus mon bonheur
c'est autant la vie de tous les jours
que le travail qui est sur place à la
forge le contact des multitudes que j'en
dis pas qu'ils viennent du nord du sud
de l'est de l'ouest
on a quand même des gens qui passent des
clients prendre le temps d'essayer de
les accueillir d'essayer de d'être
disponible sans que ça soit je te donne
ma pièce tu donnes ton fric c'est un peu
ça
[Musique]